why was he so offended by durian he
really was yes and he responds to the
durian like this yes
shows he's still competitive oh man not
only you have to beat yourself and you
have to beat everyone when you look at
these two what do you know that it's
from the 90s to today it's just a
completely different animal when you
shut a competitive you infill do you see
a lot of commonality with them as well
in the middle of conversation he
disappears you thought phil was a shy
guy yes then I got a crazy question for
you who did you think in 18 should have
won the stolen beer
I won't say that exactly you're away
from your wife with three years for
$400,000 I don't think so we know it's
about making money
it's a business will they trust you just
a question they say you know you go to
Kuwait coz Kuwait has the best drugs you
hear that all the time that's not really
true would you like to see a full lineup
next year 2020 of build ties Romney even
Roden everybody to be there I know I'm
dangerous no matter who comes back do
you think you can beat these guys
[Music]
so today I have a special guest
obviously about a month ago I
interviewed Dorian Yates and after we
interview Dorian Yates Dorian made some
comments and we were going back and
forth but I said look if we got to do it
this way we have to figure out a way to
get the current mr. Olympia 2019 meaning
the most latest champion who also want
Arnold Classic 2019 and he's got an
incredible insight on what's happening
today in mr. Olympia obviously with the
training that he hasn't Kuwait and what
he did with oxygen and all these that we
a lot of things to cover here today but
it's my distinct pleasure to introduce
to you the 2019 mr. Olympia Brandon
Currie Brenda thanks for coming on it's
a pleasure man a pleasure to be here
definitely it's good to have you here
and one of the things I got to tell you
just had a birthday your October 19 yes
yes so you're 37 7 now sir
and I'm October 18th so we're a day
apart so I turned 41 you turn 37 we'll
have our lady - yeah we're somehow
someway connected but based on our month
were boy they were born exactly and you
know extreme studies have been done to
prove that October babies are the best
human beings in the world I don't know
if they would agree with that or not
well I've never read no studies but I
can agree with its it's I've never read
them as well but I would like to believe
they exist okay so let's get right into
it you know a couple things when I look
at your personality and I see how you
are and you know you go a little bit
into your story and you're watching
yourself and some of the transitions
you've made from who you were to where
you are today you you you seem more
reserved than a lot of the competitors
out there you kind of think to yourself
you kind of seem quiet you kind of seem
the guy that's even a possible introvert
would you categorize yourself as
somebody that is an introvert or no I'm
not a completely introvert but I can
play one very well which one are you
more than oh let's see what kind of be
like like if I weigh I typically weigh
my scene weigh the scene out and that
kind of dictates what I wear I go as far
as being introverted or extroverted the
more comfortable I am with people the
more accelerated of course I become
but this decision situation is it's
pretty much dictates but I like to
observe them watch like the people watch
a lot so that's probably what keeps me
you know quiet because I'm thinking to
myself of analyzing things so you're
observant exactly God okay so if we were
in high school together
who was Brendan curry we were high
school high school Brandon Currie was
the probably let's see I the cool guy
that you know was pretty much friends
with everybody no matter what side of
the tracks they may have been from all
groups of people I was a pretty good
athlete I really wanted to want to
ascribe to be a great athlete and I was
I like to be a leader in that in that
sense as well so on the field I was you
know I was very very vocal aggressive or
you were and I and I like to set the
stage you know as far as with the
example more than anything because I
believe that you know you know people
feed off your energy and that's one of
the things I loved about the weight room
as well in high school back in the
weight room it's not the guys weren't
serious about training but I was serious
about training and that seriousness made
other other guys in the gym serious
about training and I kind of changed
that dynamic of the weight room as well
as the team dynamic as well so you know
it's for me in high school I was a good
student as well because my parents
required it that of me but school was
easy for me as well so it wasn't school
was easy yeah it was easy it was easy
for me my dad told me the other day he
said I never seen burn his study for
anything and it was telling talking to
someone else and I'm thinking myself
yeah I didn't I didn't know I didn't
study a lot my mom was always on me
about applying myself because she said I
didn't you know I didn't do over the
over the expected you know I just did
enough to be got it to be you know cool
with it and I stress over it so and I
always worked good under pressure as
well a lot of my best projects a lot of
my best work was you know kind of that
last minute you know putting it all
together grinding so were you were you
the eighth
lead was there an element of you where
you were hung out with the tough guys
the bad guys the athletes the 4.0 GPA s
or we the one that pretty much got along
with everybody
I got a nice I got along with shooting
everybody I can see that I can see that
and and what was your favorite subject
in high school you know one of the
favorite subjects I think was geometry
on the tree
yeah it's geometry everybody hated my
geometry teacher but she was an older
Italian lady I mean everybody hated her
upset me and I actually I don't know why
I liked her but I liked their class and
geometry was something no I was I just
kind of picked up naturally you know I
was kind of good and she liked me for it
and my wife was also in her class was
also a class favorite of hers back in
the day as well so so your wife was also
in the class with them well yeah in a
different class and I was but in the
same class as the same teacher and
geometry told me did you like the
theorems the cpctc what what stop just
maybe maybe I'm just more visual I guess
that was one of my it's like proven like
theorems and going through them and
what's given or what's not I don't know
why I don't know why connected to me
that that much but I just remember that
being a standout subject I was I was in
a business program at the school I think
was called MBA or whatever was called
and I was also pretty good at accounting
but I had no interest in it accounting
classes as well so my teacher was always
encouraging me he should do this you
should do that you should do that but I
just I couldn't I didn't have an
interest in seeing myself in that
environment as an accountable being on
day to day so even though I picked up on
it really well mmm it just wasn't
something I was interested if I was your
best friend who did I say brain is gonna
grow up to be XYZ was there something
that people said bran is gonna grow up
to be this or was it unknown well in
high school my wife told me I should
grow up to be a bodybuilder
she said that in high school oh yeah so
after she saw she saw me I turn a back
flip oh I think we're an opulent hotel
doing the Christmas lights lighting and
I turned a back flip somewhere and she
saw my shirt go over my head and he
lifts up and she looked at me you should
be a bodybuilder when you go
of course at the time I looked at her
and I said I don't know be on stage in a
speedo and have all all over me you know
I had no interest but I think it was a
year later that I'd actually that
competed my first bodybuilding contest
and I went overall when middleweight guy
with no plans well yeah with no real
plans I mean I prepare for that show
generally four weeks out I only did it
because a personal trainer was he kept
bugging me about it he kept asked me
that I want to compete you know you
should compete compete and and I was
just like no no I don't want to but I
got to thinking about it I guess one
night after you asked me I said I'm in
the gym or not playing college football
anymore I might as well do some of my
time you know it's maybe something I can
you know I could have some motivation to
come in here and push harder mm-hmm so
he gave me my diet showed me how to pose
and before you know what I was onstage
not worried about my opposing trunks but
just trying to figure out how to present
myself the best I could on stage and I
was like I said I wasn't a novice to the
middle weight and overall class and that
just hooked me is that this one or this
is a different one this is hmm that was
that one this was the one this was the
first one yeah that was that one yeah it
was like 19 there's 19 years old when
you want it now what do you think about
when you see this yourself now you know
I saved few occur man I my perception of
myself was was much greater than it
would be today like I had superior
confidence in myself like I was I
thought it was way more than I was I
even have forms back in the day that
would attest to that place you were very
confident here it's very comfortable
really very good Oh were you generally a
pretty confident guy uh I think I think
I was generally confident in most in
most areas like but I was also you know
Dillon high school you also worried
about how people would look at you that
allows you of course being growing up
but I think generally in most of most of
my cases I was very very confident
specially if if it was something that I
knew I could
grassed or excel it was mom and dad very
much about affirmations to you Brenda
you can do anything you want to do when
you
were they tough was it constantly
feeding positivity into you I think my
dad was more of a perfectionist and he
didn't encourage me to be my best and
pursue but he never directed me in any
way fashion he just kind of let me do as
I chose and he worked all the time so he
worked very very hard and and I saw my
dad as a very very talented person with
a lot of abilities very good people
person people skills a good leader good
at management but I think he kind of
sold himself short with what he pursued
he I was working for the body mmm and I
felt like he was the type of person that
could really really excel and you know a
lot of people like my dad will follow my
dad anywhere he could excel on his own
he didn't need to be some some company
man and my mom she was a stay-at-home
mom most of my life and I say she was
hard on me but she probably needed to be
because I was a very very hyperactive
child yeah you were high price yeah very
hyperactive shot will you ever shy were
you ever perceived as being shy or no I
don't think I was ever perceived as
being shy from the stories out here I
don't think I was ever seen I like like
I ready to my party had a birthday party
recently and one of the guys I remember
back as a childhood is his name was Kent
Kent white he worked with my dad first
big guy I ever really seen in public and
these stories I remember because my dad
tells me all the time but he's like he
comes up to me and I see him I go hey
you know I called Willie for whatever
reason he called you will come here on
him what I called him with Conner and
this is like you know one of the most
muscular guys I've ever seen he showed
me some pictures of him he's still
powerless into this day and is you know
in a minute Masterson his incredible but
his first big guy scene and I'm just
thinking I seen this big guy first thing
I called him out of his name I don't
know and I must have been an interesting
show they diagnosed me with they didn't
have a TD but hyperactivity they wanted
to medicate me as kid my parents didn't
agree with that they just felt I should
be more active so they got me in to
gymnastics as a kid so the kind of my
energy levels because apparently my mom
tells me I have three son she said I was
all three of them it's payback you know
I was all through it and you know I was
just I don't know like I was I was high
energy always happen to do some outside
all the time you know I was I was a very
very active kid I had two sisters
younger sisters and I could only play
with him so much before I was in trouble
so I learned to separate myself because
my games that we play did not organize
would always end up being some kind of
traumatic crying emotional very creative
if your brain a very like do you go
creative imagination like you're like
Marvel do you like you know certain
movies that it's all about creativity I
think I'm more create I'm more probably
more creative internally then actually I
don't I don't necessarily embrace Marvel
I'm not a comic book guy I admire those
things but I don't really embrace those
things but when it came to like creating
activities during dead times or games
you know I would always be able to be
able to entertain myself and and and
entertain others entertain themselves
they would say I cheat a lot they said I
would always change the rules and I see
my sons now when my sons is marvelous
and he playing with his little brother
he does that too and I think my oldest
son Maximus I can catch him doing it too
so I can I can see where that you know
during these games you kind of played
the rule to get the event the advantage
that uh you can't over whoever you
planned which was the one that's got the
physique that took the phone away made
that video cuz he's his back is legit
marvelous is the middle my middle son
and and he's the most into the body
booting well I say he's the one that
started to be the most into the bar now
my oldest son and my younger son are
kind of they kind of zoned into it a
little bit more than they were but he
was the one we could find Polaroid's his
sister got a camera for one of her
birthday's and we got Polaroids we found
in the house this guy he's maybe three
years old maybe him and his brother and
he's gained his brother his two-year-old
brother or whatever they take pictures
of them and they're posing and we got
these little Polaroids
and I still got his day because they're
so cute crazy yeah so he's always been
like that
you know he's always been the one
opposed of course his little brother
he's followed him and posing with him
but he's the one and he's the one that
he wanted to I went to Dexter Jackson so
he wanted to pose on stage you know I
wasn't there to guess pose I was just
there to make an appearance say hi he's
like he wanted to be on stage and he's
so serious about it after we got off he
looked at me he said dad you think I
want and I said son that wasn't a
competition exhibition nobody won so
that's a sign of admiration towards
their father by the way I mean they're
looking at you saying you know I want to
be like daddy when I grow up you know
it's it's not when you see that the kid
has really got a lot of spective respect
for their pops now in high school just
out of curiosity what was your GPA in
high school I was pretty close to
probably 3.7 3.9 I pretty close to 4.0
3.7 3.9 close pretty close pretty close
to that I'm a very good grace rarely did
I make a seee or anything like that so
if you didn't go to bodybuilding rod and
there was no interest there who would
who would have Brandon Currie be today
at 37 be interesting and it had to be
something I was being very interested in
passionate about my mom my mom is the
other day she said I could have been an
engineer you know she said you know I
could have been an architect you know
she says all these things but you know
I'm one of those persons people that if
I don't have purpose in something it's
not gonna it's not gonna drive me you
know I like to be I like to pursue
something that I know or I feel that you
know is my niche to pursue and then I go
after it but if it's if it's not the
case then I'm I'm not that I may not be
that interested makes sense in the
personality category if you look at
there's the extremely organized folks
who you go into the closet
black black black grey grey grey white
white blue blue purple purple
everything's organized socks shoes
that's the organized folks obsessive
everything's very like they know
everything's at clean crystal clean the
teeth is very technical analytical
numbers detailed data I'm missing
this part in the triceps this is not
strong I got a I won't see it with my
eyeball you'll notice yeah we're off
over here we got to cut this part up we
got to get them days out the diet proper
everything's detailed the action is the
super-competitive comes into a room
steals the show everybody knows he
entered the room she enter the room is
the a and then he had the relationship
which is all about hey man I love you
friendship bonding harmony all of that
stuff where would you put your lead I
was trying to relate to one of those but
I don't know if I can I'm not very
obsessive-compulsive but when I do
organize even though it's a mess I know
where everything is
it's like me being gone along timing
training come back home I put everything
where I know it's all come home and I
come home and I'm not home in my own
home because my wife and my kids are
moving everything around and I haven't
been there at habit to put it where I
normally would but it's not necessarily
like this conscious organizational thing
for me it's just placements I plan may
be playing something to be something
worth somewhere convenient when I needed
it at all times so maybe that's I don't
know if that's a special composure but
that's how I organize I don't have to be
the guy when I walk into a room that you
know everybody has to know I'm in there
I kind of I kind of like to not be seen
more or less a lot of people like my
wife walks with me and she's like you
know look at this person looking at you
look at this person looking at you and
I'm like man I must be like a horse with
blinders on because I don't I don't
really notice people analyzing me now I
may analyze people but I don't notice
always people analyzing me in a room and
I'm not really on the number type person
either you know exacts and I don't
analyze my physique with with like the
OCD scrutiny as well I know where I'm
where I'm lacking I know where I can
prove but I'm not the person that is
looking in the mirror every day like I
have people that that messaged me and
asked for advice and I'm like these guys
drive them so crazy because they'll send
me pictures and
and and they're always obsessing over
this and this little thing and how's
this how's this I mean you take this
stuff way more seriously than you should
is it's like you wasting time with
stretching over everything when you
could be you don't need to I mean it's
not your job it's just your hobby you
know so I look at those guys and those
guys interested me too so I don't know
where I fit to be honest I don't know
where I fit you could tell me maybe
yeah no I mean just from reading the the
interviews and reading a lot about you
and seeing what your wife says about you
and where you're at you know I think
your wife said something about the fact
that I know my husband I know my his
strength and I know where his areas of
improvements are if he's home he has to
drop off the kids in the morning he has
to be at the practices he has to be
around the family seems like family is
very important yeah there's your
relationship guys so you know maybe
you're on the relationship side were
somebody who takes a liking into you
even a guy that recruited to go to
Kuwait if if you know the person is has
the good intentions for you and you
trust them then you're willing to go out
there and be loyal to them so maybe your
first is our I don't know but I think
there's an analytical side as well you
know are you and Phil do you see a lot
of commonality with him as well
personnel because he's also the 3.7 GPA
but he went to Colorado State he was
gonna be an accountant that's the
direction he was going in seems like
both you guys are you know he was an
athlete he went basketball I think you
went football there's some similarities
as well in your personalities there
there's some similarities but I only
notice the differences I've met Phil
before field was the big field eath I
remember flipping through magazines in
2006 if we see magazine of course and
just now getting into bodybuilding I'm
seeing this Phil Heath guy and he's got
this great physique and of course he's
young and everybody's talking about him
I'm looking at him I'm thinking wow
timing this guy is coming out right
before me goodness gracious
and not only that but I had a form name
or an emo name that I made probably
maybe the year before
it's called Brennan's gifted and they
start calling the gift and it was like
this gracious Annie took something that
I nicknamed you know you know I was like
man he took that too so you know had a
spotlight on it so I'm thinking man I'm
making the whole time I'm thinking and I
guess gotta catch up to this guy right
so I get on the national level finally
and and I'm seen and everybody takes
notice one of the people to take notice
was his coach Hani rembo awkward honey
and of course I guess he saw the talent
so I'm thinking now I'm working with
lluís coach this is like man it's like
not even a year ago looking at mag him
in the magazines Hermione's physique and
success so then I get to meet him and
phil has a persona of course it's at a
public a lot of people have opinions but
I meet a shy guy you know you're shy guy
I met a medicine guy you met a shy guy
yeah you thought phil was a shy guy yes
when I when I met him I met a shy guy
better kind of like a shy shy guy I mean
I understand that I damn o'clock people
similar day but when I met Phil I'm I
think I'm gonna fail first in Hawaii and
I was my wife now I was out there to
help her for contest he was guest posing
at the event it was me Bob Carell Sean
right there they introduced me in
Phillies and we're standing there and
I'm like hey let's feel Etha that's cool
you know but in the middle of
conversation he disappears where did he
go where did he go it's like he was kind
of come aside and then of course when
you perform his guest pose and
everything came posed by me and you know
did his thing he's performing but then I
got an opportunity to you know Sam well
several occasion he's always seemed like
he was a little bit shot at me I don't
know why and then in my room at the
Nationals when I work with honey he came
in my room he's preparing for his pro
debut the biggest he'd ever been like
Bing is he'd ever been he was like to
sample my scone the room is 270 and
times like taking your shirt off take
your shirt off so what you got he's like
no no I can't take my shirt off in front
this guy I know I'm getting ready for
contest but I'm not into that nothing
like that so I always precede him as
this is this shy guy you know and that I
was kind of kind you know we always had
camaraderie and friendly and I respect
him you know a lot I mean he I respect
him a lot I understand the struggle what
it must be like to be the first social
media Olympia champion that I mean
that's a lot of learning uh yet you have
to do trial and error because nobody had
ever done it and of course he made some
mistakes and you know people criticized
him for it but I can't say that wouldn't
ever be me any better I've learned I've
learned from him what not to do you know
in a sense but so you know I respect the
guy a lot but I've always felt like I've
been chasing him and even to this day
you know I'm the champion
but I go record I still want to compete
head-to-head against them or you do want
to compete at it again I do like you
know I do so I mean I've always wanted
to but I wanted to be ready and thinking
about it last year thinking he was gonna
be in Olympia this year I was trying to
get him to just tell me he was gonna be
in Olympia at the Arnold is that what he
just put me on fire for the Olympia but
it didn't really happen so he recently
showed his abdominals and I got one on
record has said it feels shows us
abdominals and he's didn't I'll take him
seriously about potentially competing so
now I'm processing this and I see up
show us abdominals thinking maybe you
heard me and I'm like okay so now
prepare myself to compete in his field
because he comes to the stage or not but
for me it's a good thing it's a good
thing he did show up or didn't show up
no it's a good thing that he showed us
his midsection because now I'm in the
mindset that he's competing you know
he's planning to compete and preferably
against me so give me 20 20 yeah exactly
so that's a that's a good thing for me
so who else would you like to see being
it because you know and I like the
approach you took and what you said
because you know how sometimes are you
basketball guy or sports guy uh
you know what since I stopped playing
college football I'm not really a sports
guy oh really yeah zero so just go again
yes why I don't know if you remember
when the Rockets won the two
championships do you mean Wanda Rockets
one of the two championships yeah the
wrong was in two years when Co when
Jordan was gone he was retired he
stepped away from the game and Barkley
Ewing
you know Malone Stockton allows you on
all these guys are like let's go get a
couple right now and it was a dogfight
Reggie Miller everybody wanted to get
the rink as mike is out right right so
those two years allows your own picks up
two of them Houston Rockets right and
then Jordan comes back the next year and
then it's he wins three more in a row
what you just said if I'm reading into
it cuz you know you know in in the in
the in the boxing world sometimes you
got Mayweather would get heat because he
never faced off against Pacquiao is
prime and he would you know you're
saying you want to you want to go up
against these guys to see if you got the
goodies to compete against them is that
is that what you're saying exactly I
respect Phil and I think he's got a
crazy physique and it's nothing and I
wanted to see more than to be compared
to him in real life in real time you
know all stage you know bringing
bringing bringing my best and I know if
anybody's capable of helping me bring a
better or best it'd be feel because I
looked up to him from all this this
point it's like me chasing Dexter
Jackson finally chased down Dexter
Jackson I was chasing them for years but
you know now that I've beaten him it's
like man it's crazy now I need something
else to chase so yeah I guess I'm still
hungry so are you are you are you kind
of campaigning for these guys you know
for you know would you like to see a
full lineup next year 2020 or filled
guys Romney you know all the big you
know even Roden everybody to be there of
course man of course of course I'd like
to see it I think everybody like to see
it I mean the bodybuilding community
would like to see it I would like to see
it as a fan of bodybuilding and as a and
as a competitive person I'd like to see
it then I got a crazy question for you I
got a crazy political question for you
so this is obviously this is 2018
right Rodan beads Phil he okay
I was in Vegas when this happened and I
spoke to Phil and I had a conversation
for a couple hours together and we look
at this and you read a lot of news
afterwards in your sin well that was
really Phil Phil should have won it
how could Rodin win with no triceps he
didn't have any triceps is it possible
to him without triceps well maybe yes
because there's been other people in the
past that have won without biceps so
what's the big deal who did you think in
18 should've won mr. Olympia Sean oh
really
you know why midsection not just mr. he
went in mentally oh he wanted mentally
yeah he did you elaborate he won
imminently you could see it like I was
there competitively
you know Phil who was that uh I was
watching Phil the whole time analyzing
him and he was just trying to prove he
had improved where people were
criticizing his midsection and that's
what that was really his focus we
noticed that you know Phil's he came a
little bit downsized from the year
before and as things played out
I just since phil was laboring and
working way harder than he should have
been interesting stage it was just like
not the typical polished feel that I I
don't know what he was struggling with
but I've seen Dexter Jackson do that at
the Arnold that year as well and but I
seen feel doing it and he was just
struggling and put my old poses
everything and just you know really in
presentation in that point you know Sean
took advantage of that and kind of let's
embarrass them you wouldn't be able to
see that about pictures pictures don't
tell you that story and somewhat the
part where he stands up and he pauses
and it was that one that's one of the
major examples but it was it was
happening during the whole the whole
comparison rounds Phil laboring Phil
getting into poses slow you know Sean
just basically saw most days polished to
him and so on that he mentally was was I
guess ready for the title at that point
yeah I know Sean has holes in his
physiques but you know we are none of us
are perfect but I think when it came to
be him being judged and prepared to fill
the judges saw
that interactional stage they saw that
dynamic and they saw feel kind of it's
confidence fade and you can judge the
champion on that it's all mental man
what I'm saying is the judgment part
yeah we'll just a judgement judgement
part what's going on in your head I
think can reflect Oh to what the judges
see of you on stage I think it's just
like that uh you know it's kind of that
telepathic kind of communication that we
we we know exists but we don't fully
understand we you against competitors we
you against the judges ever no guys the
judges are my mirror if I'm on stage the
judges are my mirror
let me ask you when you're posing or
you're looking at them where you're
looking at the audience I'm doing a
little bit of both closer you could be a
surgeon you could be looking at the
judges as well yeah I'm doing a little
bit of blind why are you looking at the
judge if I need if I need to understand
what's going on onstage that I don't see
I'm looking at the judges huh if I want
the feedback if I wanted to know if I if
I got the edge if I want to know you
know a my favorite I'm looking at the
judges they're telling me everything I
need to know if if the judges are
ignoring me which I've been on staging
this happen before that's a bad sorry
that's a bad sign if they're not into it
if if I don't see them you know
analyzing things properly if I'm not
seeing any emotional expressions on
anybody's face at any point in time when
I feel like I'm giving something then
that I may be a little worried do you
feel that do you feel that on stage
they're not even looking at you oh yeah
you do feel them you know okay so for
him he had the physique to win it so
you're not saying he didn't have the
physique to win it I think you know phil
has a lot a lot of weapons a lot of
weapons that that you would say with any
weaknesses he have that would that would
overshadow and this conditioning was
good - it wasn't as he's in bad
condition a lot of people say that but
it's kind of like what I understood
about Ronnie's ring you come in you have
an issue they say okay we'll let you
have that
but listen you're gonna have to correct
this if you want to win another title
and I can't I feel like Phil was in the
same predicament that's why he was so
look he backstage like my midsection is
good you know trying to confirm that
with everybody media everybody looking
but I don't think once he got on stage
the opposing conditioning he was in his
ability to control and hold it I don't
think that told the proper story and
that's what he was being criticized on
he's becoming credit he's being judged
against his self so what you are saying
I just want to restate this is that his
physique physique not meant you could
tell Shawn was confident there's no
question about it but his physique beat
Rodin's physique I won't say I won't
saying I won't say I won't say that
exactly you won't say his physique being
rodents won't say it exactly because
because it's the body bone game was
interred all your friends would roll you
just principle okay your friends would
filthy it as good as I'm sure our
friends were both for these guys I'm
done and so both of them know what
you're talking about both it's a
combination of thing because when body
boo and they judge you against yourself
so everybody's critical of me you know
my first Olympia I win oh I'm not I'm
not a hundred percent
I'm not best condition I can be well
that's a compliment to me because all I
got to do is improve it for myself you
know for next year and I'm gonna be more
dangerous sure and say if I came in yeah
you know this great champion in the
beginning with was you know perf
perfectionist you see it then where do I
go from there and you know if I'm if I'm
there already where do I go from there
if I can win a title and I'm not there
already then it makes me more dangerous
then if I win a title and I'm so speak
there already and I fall off if the
desire matters yes of course if I feel
you know if I'm if I'm not even I'd
leave room to be to be beat because the
body bone is almost about beating
yourself as much as it is beating the
competitors because not only do you have
to when you witness the champion not
only you have to beat yourself and you
have to beat everyone yeah and it's this
unsaid thing and bodybuilding that Shawn
he beat his last appearance clearly
he killed it because he plays fifth that
you move yeah you're right near before
Phil he didn't improve
he didn't improve from the pretty neat
to though it should be troughton because
you know it's like it because the like
think about it in the NBA or in sports
where they would say well you know
sometimes Michaels the same as he was
last year because of that let's give the
MVP to somebody else you know LeBrons
the same as you was last year because of
that let's give the MVP to somebody else
but LeBrons still the same this year as
last year still better than everybody
else which means even if phil comes at
the same level as he was last year it's
still better than everybody else on this
day he wasn't at the same well you don't
you don't agree with that statement oh
he wasn't at the same way okay so so so
if that's the case now let's go to the
next part
Rodan this is for me i'm not in your
world and i told us to fill and i told
us to during the eight and and we got a
lot of other mr. Olynyk folks that are
coming on here i think i don't know
where else we have scheduled i think
Ronnie's coming Ronnie's coming so we
got a few other that are coming soon for
me I look at the brand from the outside
I come from the 90s era when I followed
by I was in the Army I had everybody's
poster on the wall I know you and I said
what kind of both come from the 90 side
and I had a I remember when ronnie place
I think 15 21 year and I'm like oh my
gosh this guy's got a sick physique I
mean this guy fee you know the next
phase if he changes it he can definitely
win the whole thing
right now remember our sombody i
remember paul de let you had all these
guys that were there and it was hot it
was competitive it was something we all
bought muscle mag muscle media 2000 flex
you know all those magazines you're in
the world and in all of a sudden similar
for me why I'm not turned on by boxing
anymore is a similar thing that happened
with with mr. Olympia and I'm gonna
state this and as a current mr. Olympia
I'm cursin are what you're gonna be
saying I asked a similar question from
Dorian in Phil as well is sometimes when
politics gets involved in a sport it
turns people off and it goes away from
the love of the game to who really won
this boxing match who wanted the de la
hoya wanted or the other gal when I did
the Canelo win it or triple G win it it
may
when I know what is going on over here
right when you're looking at these
fights what do you think about the
decision the mr. Olympia brand made to
tell Sean you cannot compete in 2019
even though it's in trial they don't
know any the information yet do you
think that's the right decision to make
hmm for me from his perspective no
business perspective well that's a hard
one because you know as a business as a
brand you know whatever happens with
this you know it's gonna reflect on you
at some point no you either deal with
that situation ahead of time or you deal
with it later it's one of the other so I
think they just chose to deal with it
ahead of time before anything was
possibly out too you know cause you know
they just wanted to kill it before it
got started which I can understand for
sure of course I think he should have
got to the benefit of the doubt and they
should have you know been impatient
enough to allow him to go through you
know the trial and that were not because
until then he's innocent and everybody's
been in evil mind and I know Italy and I
just don't I just don't see him being
guilty in my opinion I don't know all
the details but just showed my personal
opinion so you know as a business this
is it's a different story I don't know I
don't know how they made a decision but
they moved swiftly and made it they said
they consulted other industries they
said they consulted other industries
yeah well you know of course because
obviously ball and you're Brown and you
got some of these I get it okay they
said they did that they say to you guys
publicly well that's that's what the
public I guess the public I don't know
who who I don't know who said that I
think it maybe it's Bob - corella or
someone who's who made that statement
maybe was in debt who made that
statement yeah but that's what's the
that was the consensus that they
consulted other outside of themselves
and that's the conclusion they came to
which if that's what they did that's
more of them whether it's just I agree
with the decision or not
that's what they probably shoulda did
because Oh someone else alright to see
if you know what what how they made a
public statement whereas somebody else
come out and said yeah here's who we
contacted and here's what we consulted
because you know and the reason why I'm
asking this is the following reason are
you a movie guy you do you watch movies
you know I watch movies I don't have a
movie movie memory ok so there was once
a movie done with warrior was called
warrior I want to say it had Tom Hardy
in it it had Nick Nolte in it and I
don't know if you know this movie where
it's like the MMA fight and they're
gonna guys gonna put 5 million dollars
to see who's the baddest fighter out
there right and it's in it's in Jersey I
think it's an Atlantic City and the
champions end up being the two brothers
fighting for five million bucks that's a
movie right ok what's this movie have to
do with my question here's my question
the champion today when you win they pay
you what four hundred thousand dollars I
think that's the number which is a
salary of a president so you get paid
the same salary as President Trump does
is what they pay you 400,000 won for
strolling beyond me I think it's
underpaid okay I've been on the record
multiple times saying they have to be
the mr. Olympia brands got to do a
couple things one of the things they got
to do is I got to say listen our guys
use PD steroids it's out there it's no
longer the hush-hush and quite frankly
what pot used to be back in the 90s or
even back yeah back in the 90s smoking
weed was like oh my god that guy's a
drug addict that guys this that guys
that look at today you know I'm not one
that consumes it I'm not a fan of it I
like to stay fresh and I don't want to
have my mind being consumed but guess
what as somebody that politically thinks
are - each as his own you want to use it
go for it if it affects your body great
just don't affect my body and my family
I think if mr. Olympia came out and said
look our athletes use they choose here's
what they're doing the second thing is
the money if they don't make the price
bigger the purse bigger for somebody
like you agreeing to be away from your
wife and kids for two years where you're
not even seeing them but once you're
going to Brazil you fly out to Nashville
you see them for 24 hours
you going out to Brazil and even though
you were there you still found a way to
take your kids to school because it
matters to you you're away from your
wife or your two years
I mean professional athletes that do
what they do they go home to their
family maybe they're on the road trip
for like seven days nine days you're
missing out for two years to be in
Kuwait maybe being able to prepare
yourself to have your dream become a
reality for $400,000 I don't think so
this is my opinion I could be full of it
people could say you have no idea what
the hell you're talking about forget
about it
fine what happens if I'm sitting here
saying you know what Brandon I got an
idea here's what I'm doing
I'm willing to fund mister whatever
whatever we call it next year competing
as mr. Olympia during the same weekend
as mr. Olympia and to compete you have
to agree you cannot compete in mr.
Olympia is what we're saying
except our purses want first place is
million and a half second place is
million bucks third place is $500,000
and it goes from there okay do you think
that will create motivation for
competitors to say holy moly look at the
per seer maybe I want to go fight in a
place like this to get the platform or
do you think that wouldn't change
anything with the competitor saying no
I'm good also go to mr. Olympia it's a
technical question it kind of Europe it
depends on you know how how much the
competitors have followed the history of
bodybuilding I mean the IEP of course
has been challenged by some powerful
entities Vince McMahon was one of them
and he did that he pulled some body
builders away paid him more money
slats some of those rats got to compete
on on hit on his stage and you know and
a lot of guys went I made a lot of money
but it just didn't last
didn't have the foundation that uh that
IBB had so you know it was a scare first
so it depends on whether those guys
really are gonna believe it or they are
they gonna be made to believe it if it's
gonna be believable because I don't they
know what is a believable it means these
whoever is going to present this
opportunity he's got to have all their
Dougie's in life to ensure that he's you
know
these athletes are going to be secured
and believed in what they say meaning
the money the money saved up it's
credible I'm talking say it's say it's
the most credible source of money that
you know is there let's just say it's
100% credible take the biggest celebrity
today in the marketplace who's got the
most followers and everybody respects
and trust this person and they're in
shape they want to put it together pick
that person everyone knows it's legit
right and that's the purse mmm does it
change the game it does change the game
cut it does change the game for them a
lot of people I think it does but will
they trust it is the question trust what
the money or trust the opportunity will
they become through enough to say okay
I'm going to leave this security what I
know and try something new that you know
because we know it's about making money
it's a business especially to put your
body through you put your not only for
us but whoever this surety of course
right yeah so if this entity is not able
to make the money that they want the
return that they make off this
investment that they put in then they're
not no matter how much they love what
they're gonna do they're not gonna
continue to invest in it as a business
person so we have to look at it from
that end of the spectrum if they make
the return on their investment they
spending all this money yeah you have to
be able to continue to do this in order
to afford to continue and that's the
question that Ashley's are gonna have to
really ask so you know we just looked at
an office space this morning it's a big
office space beautiful office space
obviously we we have nearly 30,000
square feet of office space here we have
our employees that work here we have all
the stuff that goes on over here we need
a bigger office space 7:45 in the
morning we went to look through this
space two and a half times big as this
we would either buy this entire building
or you know be different structure that
we put together so I go and I look
through the offices I'm like wow that's
a pretty sick office space modernized it
was built in 99 rebuilt and customized
in 2015 etc etc and the company that did
it
was a very well-known magazine company
in 99 very okay now in 99 what do you
want I do we buy magazines you go to the
car magazine you go into a house make
some bathroom magazines every we go
there's mag we buy magazines and you and
I both know what happened to print it's
gone digital it's gone away we're no
longer buying magazines like we once
used to write okay
so some of the companies that adapted
their around competing those who are not
you're getting killed crushed right okay
I feel what happened to the printing
business due to digital is happening to
mr. Olympia brand because of social
media okay
some may agree some may not agree so it
it tells me as a businessman
entrepreneur investor at somebody that
looks at everything would been
investments this is a good investment
for me make 10 years from now I feel
what made mr. Olympia brand unique was a
love of the game with the guy at the top
okay
there was a storyteller mmm there was a
fascination he would look at you with
the stories out what here's a oh my gosh
Brandon look at you what you look like
is absolutely incredible right they were
fascinated by the physique Joe Weider
you obviously who I'm talking about
okay the the love of the car Ferrari for
a guy like me to buy Ferraris is because
of Enzo Enzo would sit there and watch
Mickey loud or he would watch these guys
race non-stop
so when Ferrari went public a couple
years ago and they started coming up
with this California car $200,000 car
some of the enthusiast says I don't know
if Enzo would have done this I don't
know if it's a direction they're going
do you think the brand is losing a
little bit of they'll love it again that
Joe Weider had many many years ago when
he started it or you think is just a
different story today I think it has
lost it a little bit when he when when
that turnover happened but I think you
know I think the industry has been able
to pick up a little ground a little bit
more ground since and I think that we
should give these new promoters in these
positions especially dan you know Dan is
a big fan of the
the leaders he's followed him he's made
a movie that's my story that's important
so he you know he understands he has a
really love for this moment he wants to
see it grow and I think he should be
given the opportunity to you know he had
this first year which it was a very
successful year for the Olympia
a lot of people didn't think it was
gonna be a successful year for little
people when we walked out and looked at
that crowd on Saturday night we got
offstage and that's every what everybody
was talking about was well we won't talk
about like man this place is packed out
so we're very very impressed by what
they were the production what they were
produced with their first year so I
think if we give these guys the
opportunity to do even more which I know
they're planning and they're organizing
to this day now what we say there is
doubt in the marketplace well you know
there they are their own it and now
planning for the next year hopefully
yeah yeah they are yeah I know I know I
know I know those guys are and in some
of the guys he has on his team are quite
tenacious in business as well I would
like to give them the opportunity to
actually see you know what they they're
gonna be the produce what they're gonna
be able to improve upon because they
knew it's a new opportunity these guys
they come in from a different place they
have obviously our passion for the sport
they want their desire to change things
they know it needs to be changed and and
I think there's a little pressure on
them they do that as well mother come
from other areas so I like to give these
guys an opportunity to yeah to you know
to do that
before I you know before we talk about
you know whether the Olympius is on this
downward downward spiral like we've been
talked about two years ago so so you
know I I try to put myself in your shoes
and their shoes as well right and and
and you know there's these statistics
there's one of them that just we pulled
up I did a video on it
88% of Fortune 500 companies from 1950
are not around 88% are not around that's
a crazy statistic why is it happened
you don't innovate you get cocky you
think gonna be around forever oh we're
always gonna be this great I this is my
opinion I think they mistreated Phil
Heath I think there was a different
approach to take with Phil Heath here's
a guy that sets
aside his desire to have kids and do all
of that stuff and he goes and commits to
his career to want to build it because
he wants to be a nine-time you know
irani being an eight-time he's trying to
be a nine-time maybe the first time
that's a ten-time guy to win and uh you
know hey great here's what happens all
the best
hopefully you come back next year he's
got one seven you know times you just
kind of treat him as a regular mr.
Olympia he wants seven times so he
sacrifice the desire to have a kid you
know what it is to have kids it's a lot
of responsibility and sometimes your
kids get sick you get sick that sets you
back two weeks and you know what it is
when you're hugging your kid and he
drools on you you don't know how you got
a flu you're feeling under the weather
the next you trying to work out you
don't feel the 400 percent strength
that's a risk you're taking to have kids
when you're bodybuilding
okay then I see you and I see you become
Australia and you're good citizen
everyone likes you you're a class act
everybody says nothing but good things
about you as a human being
you're great citizen too mr. Olympia if
mr. Olympia is watching this which some
tells me they're gonna be watching this
okay if they are this would be my game
if I'm them and you don't have to
comment on this I'm just gonna say this
and you can say agree disagree or say
nothing you can do whatever you want to
do with it say I'm somebody of influence
and I have money and have influence you
have the right contacts you say Pat I
want to be your right-hand guy I tell
you this is what you got to do you say
Pat I'm willing to do it I said Brandon
it's gonna take you five years to become
who you want to be I don't want to be
that no problem you go pay the price to
be my right-hand guy it is my
responsibility to do whatever I can to
have your dreams become a reality
so what does that mean you got my
contacts my investors are your investors
what deals you want to do let's do it
together you want to start something go
for it and you want to go do a cameo in
a movie you want to be in a show you
want to do this no my contacts are here
I can get you you want to write a book
I'll introduce you to Simon and Schuster
you want to go out there and do this
part I got my contacts will take care of
you my attorneys my accountants are
yours right I think mr. Olympia today
has the following opportunity to come
through and see what they can do for you
if they come through and give you what
you want whatever those things may be
and turn you into a rock star in a
marketplace to the limits that you
willing to sacrifice where it doesn't
affect your preparation for 2020 mr.
Olympia I think then if I'm gonna mark
your place and saying tank they take her
there first place like that I want to be
that I don't think they did that would
fill you I think they just kind of had
fill eat well okay we'll see again next
year again we'll see an x-ray again
we'll see you next year so that is my
biggest concern because if I'm sitting
there on a property that if somebody a
company that somebody who builds it does
it the right way they can sell it for
six hundred million dollars but the way
I'm running here right now I can only
sell 450 million dollars I'm better off
selling it to somebody for two hundred
billion dollars and leaving it up to him
to sell it for 600 million others the
point I'm trying to make I would if I'm
if I was a Mistral impe and I'm not
willing to do the part to promote the
hell out of it to get it to the next
level maybe I'm going to bring the guy
that's in the bodybuilding world and who
loves exercising pick some of the guys
in Hollywood whoever is at the top pick
pick
rock 100 some film some million
followers selim 51% of mr. Olympia work
some kind of a joint venture have them
come and run the brand I guarantee you
mr. Olympia is going to go to a whole
different level
if a guy like that's promoting it at the
time I guarantee people out of the
Woodworks will come to want to compete
to be missed or Olympia because if they
do guess what rocks gonna get you in
another movie that he's doing it you'll
get a couple lines and hey now you got
endorsements now you got this stuff
there was a benefit of playing with
Chris Paul you play with Chris Paul you
don't a State Farm commercial how many
of his teammates did State Farm
commercials all these other guys so what
do you think about that well it looks
good and that's good that sounds great
you know would you like to see mr. ol
going that direction you know of course
of course but some of that I believe is
our responsibility as an individual as a
bodybuilder myself how I present myself
to the public the opportunities I choose
to accept the ones I choose not to
you think wieder helped Arnold of course
of course he helped him you know what I
mean it's like hey I party with these
guys last week I want you to meet Arnold
and I want you to put him in a movie you
look we did those buddies but he helped
him but he also hand-selected him and he
was preferably groomed for what they
wanted to sell when to promote how much
of it you think is on the athlete how
much of you think is on the brand
lift up the players I think I think as a
business 50 50 years okay I'm with that
I'm with that I agree with them some
sports trying to go into different
countries to play to pull the other
audience for you and it just kind of
makes her contract more because if the
league gets bigger then is you getting a
bigger payday so Roger Goodell who wants
a 50 million dollar year's salary but he
signed a 10 20 billion dollar contract
with the TV and everybody that owned an
NFL team their network just won a 50%
he's doing his part as a league that's
the question that's the part I'm saying
that the guys at the top at most role
impure gotta do something for me to say
I want to go computer mr. oh well you
know they have an advantage over us
who's they
delete itself mr. Olympia exactly why
the advantage is they know as athletes
we're in the sport because we love it we
love it exactly maybe even other sports
bother maybe even more than other sports
because it's the pain is actual side
effects that could be actual side
effects long-term would bones with you
know like football can concussions you
guys got some stuff like look what
happened right now with flex wheeler hmm
you know there is some some stuff that
you may pay a price 10 15 20 years from
now so if you're willing to put your
body through that I've got to protect
you that's just my thoughts yes that's a
good that's a good place to be and these
discussions these discussions matter
they're important because things don't
change without all right I hope they're
having it man I hope so to go past this
topic here so you would like to see a
full lineup 20/20 so Phil is watching
this guy is watching this if all these
guys are watching it you would like to
see a full lineup next year to see how
it's gonna turn out everybody would like
to see a full lineup I would I would be
motivated out of my mind if I know I was
gonna be able to get a full lineup that
does something a preparation off for
22news with me and my coach we we we got
a lot to prove man a lot of people are
talking and we love it motivates us to
get better and that's what this sport is
all about is getting better so with that
opportunity I'm gonna try to get better
regardless but you know you know certain
things for our you up and that's just
one of those things there's an athlete
that will fire me up I look at your deal
man I look at your physique like again
like when I show this to during I'm like
did
is crazy to me but if all of these guys
come back to want to compete all of them
what what do you your technical I don't
see it from your lens I'm not looking at
from your lens how much more can you
improve to beat these guys next year doe
because well well it was pretty this way
I'm honest with this my conditioner was
better earlier this year at the Arnold I
did have a little bit more size for this
show me bringing the conditioning that I
have for honor which is one show
prepping for one show I'm always let's
see it's always easy to prep for one
show then that's right then multiple
show especially if the shows say I have
to start all over again with my
preparation if the shows are closed it's
like you just kind of stay in range but
in once you have to prep shut it down
start all over again the body may act a
little different a lubbers isn't it
that's why so few people wonder Arnold
and the Olympia in the same year it's
just it's just harder to do that's why
there's respect they already do that
it's just harder to do so I just know if
there's one show coming into Olympia
conditioning will not be the factor I'll
be super Chris so you're not your normal
this year no not doing it okay so I'll
be super fresh got it you know my body
will not be stressed from any other
competitions and I'll be ready
definitely ready to go and with the
improvements I've been making from year
to year I'm kind of into prom what they
call a prom right now the prove Mazar
for me I feel like in evitable long as I
keep working hard putting my work in the
improvements and quality are inevitable
my ass quality everything is inevitable
because I'm right I'm right in the meat
of where we say this is body butter
sweet spots exactly so I you know said I
know I'm dangerous no matter who comes
back these guys they got to be they got
to come back with at their best and you
know you know that's not easy so if they
do if they come at their best and you
come at your best I'm talking no Arnold
Classic you're not coming you know
Phil's not gonna door no plastic if he
comes back if he comes back and all
these guys come back with the normal
classic hypothetically do you think you
can beat these guys and win it again
next year 2020 cuz that's a big one mr.
Olympia 2020 will be remembered I
wouldn't I will not desire it as if I
don't think I could win okay
I don't want to do this this is just for
participation ribbon I want to I want to
challenge I want to respect and I want
to responsibility respect that I only
you know that's what I want I respect
that a lot I know you went from 2011 you
were eight seventeen you were eight
eighteen you were fifth and in nineteen
you were first and you went up against
William Chopin Dexter Dexter fourth
place at 49 years old to me it's just
insane to look like that at 49 years a
nice to follow this guy 20 years ago
like you know so so so let's let's get
to our buddy's question here not one of
the things I'd want to spend some time
on is a little bit of Kuwait before we
wrap it up but comparing you know the
whole thing about you again you get this
in sports which is like we know our era
of bodybuilders were better than your
era of bodybuilders right I mean it's
normal
sometimes it's pride for the older
generations to say you know I think we
are at a better place than yours but you
know you look at this and Dorian I
respect them a lot but when you look at
these two what do you notice from the
90s to today I mean this is obviously
where you were competing versus when
these guys were competing what's the
biggest difference well the biggest
difference from what you see today is
today you'll see literally every photo
from a show on any date bra back then
every photo you saw was out of magazine
chosen edit it for for marketing
purposes very good so you can't you
can't really social media change the
game on how you can even compare to to
to be honest and photography is way
different you know even have
high-definition cameras and you know 4k
and all that kind of stuff back in the
day you know they even even the way they
lit they lit the stages were different
it's just a completely different animal
when you try to competitive but I I'm
just happy Dory to be critiquing me
opportunities a champion like him
critiquing critiquing me yes this is my
respect and it shows me it shows me
exactly why he wants so many
championships shows he's still
competitive
I want to play this - what he said
obviously you've seen this I want to
play this to you and then I want to read
your response and I'm curious to know
what you're gonna say when you know what
you're thinking when you when you hear
him talk about this here's what he said
how did you feel about the whole contest
did you
I mean I've see Brandon Currie won what
do you think about Brandon Currie as a
physique as a winner
well I mean I respect to all the guys up
there they're all doing their best but
if I'm to be honest and that's that's
pretty much normally what I am I feel
the standard of the mr. Olympia is not
what it used to be the whole thing's
diversified you've got all these
different categories and classes and
everything but the mr. Olympia the pure
bodybuilding itself
you had three guys there that would you
know I guess so they were pretty close
there was two guys in what I would say
pretty good shape you know they were
they were in good shape but they're
quite small guys yeah I'm William Banach
okay circle and a guy from Iran how does
show choir yeah I don't couldn't
pronounce his name very good and in good
shape but they're smaller guys they're
smaller guys and so Brandon want it I
believe because it's got more stature is
bigger it looks much more like a mr.
Olympia but he wasn't in incredible
shape so I think it was probably one of
the weaker sheikah mr. Olympia is that
that we've seen what do you look at when
you look at this I'm curious like your
eye where does it go first and then
where does it go good I look at the
average person looks at is like oh my
gosh this answer beats what do you look
at well he's got very good fullness good
roundness to the muscles and no really
noticeable weak points in that in that
pose but his lack in deep separation and
conditioning that used to be the norm in
the mr. Olympia the conditioning part
yeah the conditioning is what's lacking
there's no Kevin Love Ranas well would
you agree with that were some of the
times you would show up pretty full yeah
wasn't yeah Kevin has a right to zinc
but it wasn't consistent at that time
you know best maybe six place whatever
and then your response that came out and
I read them like
mmm like the classiest response you
could have given right I'm reading this
it says so in a nutshell it's durian
being durian nobody did it harder
stricter in as hardcore as durian we got
one legendary video to prove it he can
have that I'll just an arguably give it
to him he needs that it's his legacy so
of course bodybuilders didn't work as
hard as he did hell yeah we may rely
more on technology or peds so this makes
his way and his era better simple as
that you know why he says so and some
others would agree with them we know his
way made him a champion and some may say
the most badass hardest-working
blue-collar and grain bodybuilder that's
ever lived he can have that but this guy
right here referring to himself is
completely different and I'm totally
cool with it I got to watch a video just
the other day that put Dorian's 1993
versus 2019 Brandon head-to-head and for
pose for pose I love the comparison and
I'm happy to be just who I am as well
I'm sure he can attest to not how not
winning your first more Olympiad a
hundred percent on a vacated title makes
you more dangerous if you do improve and
continue and but your your trainer had a
complete different by the way this is
pure class like you can do class on how
to respond I'm like Brandon could run
for office minute the way he rust
responded right but your trainers took a
different approach I don't know if
you're ready is approach you didn't read
it but I know my trainer yes hello tabby
says continue smoking that you're
smokin waiting for your response oh
never mind you're irrelevant that's what
he said train no what are your thoughts
the first time you saw this and you hear
him saying that well I just like I
thought is that's just so durian train
that's so expected perspective him you
know I've seen several issues with
durian
it's pretty much the same narrative no
matter no matter who would who went he
just had a certain way of doing things
he believed in that he marketed it it
worked for him and you know everything
else is not is not not good enough and
that's fine I mean that's cool but it
doesn't really bother me I can look it I
can look at my physique I click it
comparisons and I'm like I said I'm
really happy with what I can
I'm very impressed I was very impressed
by Dorian what he was able to do yeah I
mean I respect that guy tremendously the
my said he had to have so I don't I
don't I don't really expect much
different from a champion as competitive
as Oh God so that was no when you heard
it you're like yeah it makes sense he
would say something like that exactly
but you know what's crazy like one of
the things that you guys both also have
in common
here's the thing that I noticed I both
you get some in common I asked him a
question I said what was advantage that
he had over his competitors he says I
trained in UK right away from everybody
because when you hear there's a party
all the stuff that's going on and you
would get caught up in it right and you
made a similar move two years ago where
you and your wife are like baby here's
what I got ad if I want to win I got to
go do something and then he came and he
recruited you and you decided to go to
Kuwait and train at the gym called
oxygen in a temperature of 118 degrees
dry it's not humid and an all-male gym
this is not like a gym you go to Gold's
where he got men and women and you got
ladies doing squats and deadlifts and
you're trying to distract yourself with
50 mirrors and somehow some way you can
miss the butt or whatever they're doing
is you're getting distracted we're men
so we see how that happens what are the
benefits you had of going to Kuwait and
how did that impact your victory in 2019
I first benefit having a coach that is
hard to pursue on my side believes in me
a hundred percent it's very obvious he's
a hundred percent in my corner man he's
my he's my little brother technically he
always calls me you know says he's
bigger than me Oh what do you mean
but he's my little brother but he's just
tenacious man and having that behind you
somebody that supports you in that way
and you're on the same page you know you
can really just accomplish a whole lot
it almost pretty much anything being in
oxygen gym where batter Buddha has laid
out a an incredible place for an
atmosphere for bodybuilding machines
equipments everything's picked by him
he's fully invested in what he does
you know he's asked my opinion on this
and this and that and I know his passion
for it is is it's crazy and that's why
he's so successful what he does
and I just I just feel honored that you
know he could have me be a part of that
and I just I just won't be able to
represent that brand to the best of my
abilities as well because I mean he
don't he don't have to go out his way to
be to provide me this opportunity and he
doesn't have to support bodybuilding
there's an industry as he does by
bringing some some just this new this
new flavor to bodybuilding I would say
and any in the Middle East he's created
this whole new excitement for the sport
as well and all over the Middle East so
everybody's trying to step their game up
in the Middle East because of he'll try
to compete so I mean it's crazy I mean
the convenience of the gym I live right
beside the gym he has a flat for me
right there I come down the stairs the
elevators not stairs to elevator
wall but just right next door going to
the gym is right there
restaurants there I can eat what I want
got a middle sponsor eat smart they send
my meals every day all I got to do is
text them but if I have any changes I
mean going there I could train my free
time I can just rest I can focus on what
I what I need to do to recover when
you're rest I'm just I take naps I can
catch a family I can do some research
any for my entertainment I can watch I
can just eat my coach you know he picked
me up let's go eat somewhere we'll eat
the health food restaurants Oxford
restaurant of cheap meal whatever it may
be you know it's I'm one of those people
I guess you could say I don't need to be
stimulated at all times you don't need
to be I don't need to be I guess I grew
you know I grew up with two sisters but
I say it's more like an only child in
some forms because I had to stay with my
sister support Lee because I know I
would get in trouble if I spend too much
time with him because they'd be crying
we'd be too playing the game and they
you know something happened so I spent a
lot of time to myself and and I got used
to that growing up as the only boy so me
being in this confined area spending
time to myself
all those cost others and it's not a
problem for me to be there to focus on
what I need to do plus in the back of my
mind it's like I got this opportunity to
be away from our family right I'm
spending all this time away
well I'm gonna be hearing wasting my
time like I need to give this all I got
I need to make sure I am trying to be
100% on every single day because if I
come back and I don't I don't produce
what I need to produce brandy is gonna
say what happened no I just I'm gonna
feel like I'm a complete failure you are
yeah
I'm gonna feel like I'm not complete
yeah you know me no you're not giving
these opportunities just to just to let
them you say just it's you know just did
not value them Brandon what's his
incentive what's what's their incentive
to do this I mean what is it I mean they
love the sport they wanted I mean they
want to represent and show what they
show their muscle so to speak what they
know what they understand as a coach he
wants to he wants to be the best in the
world best coach in the world you know
he who got him in the body boom why was
he so afraid about durian cuz that's the
guy who got him to pay attention to
bodybuilding he saw Dorian Dorian was
his favorite bodybuilder when he really
was yes and he responds to Dorian like
this yes Wow
because Dorian got him into a sport
Dorian got him interested in compete and
he still responds to Dorian like the a
because he is tenacious competitive this
guy psycho competitor tenacious how was
he with you is he talk to you does
he like how does he drive you is it a
you know when psychologically is messing
with you like certain coaches do now he
doesn't he don't play any tricks I've
had those tricks played on me you don't
work he it's like almost like yin and
yang he's fast I'm more slow you know
I'm gonna he's more upbeat I slowed
him down
he speeds me up it's more of that
dynamic so but he involves me you know
he's not I know it all he has a plan he
you know he he sells me to trust him I
trust him after said no I do why do I
mean you've had a lot of trainers right
what makes him different than everybody
else because I can I can see he's
genuine okay buddy who believes when he
first met me he told me um he basically
he told me how long he's been following
me
he met me in like 2010
the at the phoebo in Germany mm-hmm I
don't even remember that he remembers it
he was there when he when I did my first
Olympia you see me on the stage he
sitting there asking me what he thinks
my best look was because he's he's
questioning whether we agree yeah its
first time I met him he already had a
plan laid out he's excited obviously his
vision another thing is he has good eyes
which is a key and bodybuilding good
eyes a lot of times you could have a lot
of head knowledge you could have a you
can be educated but if you don't you
don't have vision
if you can't see what's going on you
can't make the adjustments if you if you
don't if you can't tell so if you can't
visually I guess take a snapshot I guess
see maybe yes maybe he has a
photographic memory I don't know if you
can't tell what's going on from one day
to the other just by looking at me and
reading my body then I don't care how
much you know it's not gonna be it's not
gonna buy you stuff so that's where his
talent lies and and what's special about
the gym yeah you hear about the Mathew
the mirror and all this stuff yeah but
what is what is the biggest difference
between oxygen gym and Gold's Gym Venice
Santa Monica man is this somebody puts
love into something you can tell
somebody puts passion in something you
can tell when you when you put in an
environment to where each piece of
equipment is hand selected he don't want
you don't want the publicity of of
anybody copying him so he removes all
the labels off the pieces so you don't
even know who produced it equipment
because he wants everything to be
uniform he don't want to you don't want
to highlight it mean any any of those
things he wants to show this is this is
his his own idea he's he's gonna need a
piece of gum he's felt it he understands
how it works he puts it in the gym to
provide the variations you need so much
complexity in the gym so much you can
get done I mean we keep it's no way I'm
going and do the same workout every day
you'd be bored which is you got so much
to work with
five-star gym you got yet trainers on
the floor
if I'm ever in there need a spot if I
need somebody go grab some dumbbells go
grab me some dumbbells 25 our cleaning
staff those guys are cool they help you
they take the weights off for you they
wipe everything down for you whatever
you need they'll go get you some water
if you want I mean you got the
restaurant to serve while you need is
downstairs if you need if I need to eat
when I'm there I'm just go in there and
get it massage therapy if I need to
relax in the sauna
zero-zero cold tub or the pool whatever
I need all of it yeah he's taking care
of all the needs and he and he cares
about the place he's renovating but when
we go to yeah he started a renovation
project it's a gym was already complete
he's built to enjoy sense right he
started a renovation project to what he
wants to expand a labor room put the
cross cross-strait room in the basement
yeah he don't have to do that he's not
gonna lose any members if you don't give
me an I mean make no more any more money
up cuz he did it so it's just it's just
his love and it's passionate for that
you know I can agree with it drives me
you prefer working out there than gold
is it a different kind of an environment
or is girls more history to you you know
if I work out with go work out with
goals then I wouldn't want to I wouldn't
wanna necessarily be working on it goes
our Charles now I had this opportunity
to training goes recently two weeks ago
packed rang with Charles & DEC's Charles
first time if I want to train me for
years he's there with Charles in liver
training he never trained me first time
he's been one or two for years but ask
me but this first time I've been able to
connect with Charles and train with him
and that be the dominant reason for me
to train other that goes will be not not
for vasili yourself before who was there
okay and it's kind of somewhere with
this facility itself is great but who
was there the energies is there the
Brotherhood is there everybody's there
for one reason we try to get better as
bodybuilders and we're trying to do it
as a team you see Ronnie all the time
you see when chloral are they there I
see we clear on a regular base Riley of
course is not there anymore and when
Romney was there he had a little bit of
a different schedule then than we did
cata but
Roli I see everyday live on the same
floor
you know we're tight man we've been
known each other for years so he said he
said he's another guy that's loved by
everybody
yeah only people like him a lot man I
mean he just seems like a he's a good
guy yeah he's a good fun he's a good
fun-loving guy man he loves kids he's
like a big kid himself you know and you
can tell that when you see he won't know
did he went 2080 normal classic he won
20 17 or 20 last year he won on
Australia or in Australia got it or in
Australia like here one of the things
you say in your response to Doreen is
hell yeah we may have more rely on
technology or PD how open are you about
PD yourself well it's not something that
I attend to I'm not a person that
educates people when I feel because I
don't have the background to educate
people everything I know is do personal
experience and that may not be something
that you can just you know you can't I'm
not like this guy I like that guy so and
I don't want and I'm not one of those
guys that depended on that early I
didn't believe it I didn't believe that
that's right you and Ronnie were one of
the guys that you guys naturally
competed way way past it until until
until being a pro was actually in my
reach oh we know it was the next level
it wasn't it wasn't necessary for me it
wasn't until it became my job wasn't
necessary so my thing for these young
guys is you got to come in develop your
physique completely as much as you can
without because it's gonna benefit you
down the road the more the more you come
into the game and you want to come come
bring complexity to it it's gonna it's
not gonna make it easier it's gonna come
make it more complicated because you're
thrown in more variables which means
that your body has to deal with more
variables which means there's so many
other things that can change yeah so
until you know the basis the foundation
of how to build muscle how to burn fat
why are you gonna over complicate this
process which is already complicated and
add another variable that changes the
game dynamically and dramatically you
know it's you shouldn't do that you
should learn your body know that you
know how to properly train know that you
know how to properly build muscle know -
you know how to properly incorporate
nutrition before you need an advantage
there's no there's no way you're gonna
need an advantage before you don't do
that because if you do
if you do it the other way around you're
gonna have to learn everything else over
and over again once you hit that wall
and you reach that level where those PD
is not gonna do anything for you anymore
except take more which makes you break
you were talking put your more risks so
you don't have to start all over again
and try to learn it right because you
learned it wrong and that's right so a
lot of guys especially in certain areas
color cultures even even the movie some
of those guys they think the first thing
they got to do okay
I'm training out what I got to take it's
like no that's that's not the route you
want to go it's your training out learn
your body learn how you respond we're
all a little bit different once you
learn those things then you can add a
different dynamic that you can play with
and it complicated even more but you're
starting there's no need to complicate
you see any need of doing it if you're
not gonna be competing professionally
you know what I'm saying I don't I don't
see I don't see a reason to unless you
aspire to go to a higher level right or
unless you're doing it from some kind of
antiaging benefit you know for your for
your personal health sure absolutely
well you know that's the that's really
the only reason if it's not if it's not
for competitors logical reasoning you
got there because you know how sometimes
they say you know you go to Kuwait Kiska
ways to place Middle East has the best
PD to have the best drugs way better
than us you hear that all the time it's
not really true it's not really true
it's not it's not really true the man
may be a certain Lina sees though that
we don't experience anything yes but you
know you get you get a mixed bag
everywhere you go everybody you know you
don't you know you got a you got to have
you know people that you trust or people
that you source you correctly you don't
because it's face
bull crap all over the world you know
yeah it's because money in it at the
level you know Dave poem we'll talk
about the fact that you know when you're
going if you go 12 weeks you got to take
50% off you know whether you're six
weeks off you know 12 weeks on six weeks
off 12 weeks off on when you're at the
mr. old level can you even do that or at
the mister Oliver you got to be
year-round to be able to compete at the
highest level
know at the mister level is just gonna
depend on your competition schedule if
you compete multiple times a year
that's gonna figure out how much you got
to be you know prepared but if you're
not competing multiple times a year then
you can give your body a break you
schedule those things and you pay
attention CL I mean back in the day it
criticizes us no for I made that
statement just because that's what they
speculate they speculate that we do hmm
because you know we got new things that
a lot of people like these arms and
things a lot of people think that's
that's all the rage and body pulling for
us and it's not you know most body ways
I know on a professional level we don't
really fool out with arms we may have
tried to play with them but we know
that's not the basis so that's the news
newer technology things that people talk
about but I know they competed a whole
lot more than us back in the day
ma-maybe
not Dorian cuz he's mr. Olympia but all
the other guys they compete a whole lot
more than us so I mean they use more
stuff than they competed a lot meaning
he compete more tournaments per year off
like got it so you know I don't you know
at this point you have to be on stuff
regularly talk about us like we don't
compete enough anymore but you know it's
like because you know you're not trying
to stress our bodies I've done that you
know I don't want to I don't want to
compete not hate shows you know I asked
you know Reagan Grimes talks about the
fact that hey when he was there was too
much he wanted to kind of get away from
it and then you're kind of seeing what
he said about it
well you know it's you know when you I
just put it this way when you need a
reason you can find it doesn't make it
necessarily true but that's the reason
you put there and and you put that out
there and that's the reason they got to
take it as is that may not be the real
reason hmm those are no but you know but
people will accept that because that's
what they want to believe fair enough
you what do you think about these guys
that on YouTube they'll just go out and
say this is my cycle here's what I did
here's like maybe a Boston Lloyd here's
the the stuff that I'm using this is how
you cycle you think it's you think it's
also good to go out there and kind of
share your cycles on YouTube and
encourage young people to get on because
you're seeing a lot about like even for
myself I'm seeing 16 17 18 year-olds
start talking about hey I'd like to get
on these cycles what are yours
I don't I don't think it's very
responsible unless unless you're expert
in you know endocrinology and all this
kind of stuff unless you have the
background to where you can protect
these people I don't think you should be
just stored out this little information
is it can be follow because I mean the
body woman of course is in these PD
stuff it's not it's not cookie cutter
you know what works for one person just
like any other drug from any other
companies it may not work for you just
because we are supposed to give you an
erection doesn't mean everybody that
takes Viagra was gonna get her an
erection you know somebody somebody's
gonna get those side effects that they
put on that commercial pour and
somebody's not yeah you know you know so
you you you have any these kids maybe
unknowingly what all the information out
now they shouldn't be unknowingly to be
honest so let me ask you what what book
you recommend reading if I know nothing
about I don't want to use anything but
I'm thinking about I want to go be a
body well there what book should I wait
to get more educated on PD steroids all
these things one of the most complete
guides that I that I've come across and
I actually have it's how to be your own
bodybuilding coach by dr. Scott Seiver
Stephenson's who was a very very
educated guy and he but he's able to
take very very complex information and
kind of break it down to where people
can can understand it and in its
complexities and he takes a you know a
very conservative safe health-conscious
approach from his experience even
training that diet everything he lays
out even lays out two different
differences so you can have your your
options of variations because he knows
everybody's not the same as soon as you
start talk to to dr. Scott he's gonna be
like if you don't know something he
doesn't know anything he doesn't know it
but he's gonna say okay but within this
scenario maybe this is the case but in
this scenario maybe this is the case he
understands the complexity of what we do
and a sport and he's a very educated man
and he's been around a long time and he
still competes he's competed recently I
competed this year he's an amateur level
but he's very educated and you when you
speak to him he's gonna give you a
wealth of very interesting I like that
we're gonna put the link below we're
gonna put the like I like smart people
man and I'll follow some more people
and he's one of those guys that I really
really respect his opinion you know I
want a lot of other guys like such as
John Meadows and and and see Jordan
Peterson it's a lot of good resources
out there
Jordan Peter you drop Jordan Peterson
and this no no no no no not not the body
but the body wouldn't work
Oh from the UK UK I'm missing for this
modern age these guys they don't have
books but they have actual web web
subscription sites where you can watch
videos you heart any form and all those
times you get educated before you make
it this is it this is gonna affect your
health and it's best to know what you're
doing before you have a friend of mine
math guy man before he does anything he
bought every one day I want to sat down
with him we're having lunch he told me
all of these things he got about
steroids then he said I'm thinking about
doing this like okay but I respect the
fact that he read every paper from
doctors from this and he pretty much
gave a presentation I said good for you
for a second I thought and he's always
like that about everything he does it
last topic before we get into a couple
things here House flex doing what's
what's the you know obviously a lot of
people in the bodybuilding world love
flex and admire him how's this help well
you know I saw I was with Flex two weeks
ago at the memorial service of Franco
Columbu and we actually said I said
right beside him doing it don't know the
service said no and you know I could
tell someone's weighing on him a little
bit but you know he was there trying to
enjoy everything at the moment and you
know I know I've been thinking about
ever since then and then I hear this
just come out and I was like man this is
it's crazy if it's not one thing it's
another for flex you know and he
happened to hit me up yesterday because
he realizes my birthday and you know you
checked on me he wished me happy
birthday I'm like man this guy I'm
thinking myself I know I know he's
probably being bombarded you know with
people questioning what's going on and
he had you know he had the nerve the
the modern it fulness to think about me
when she figured I was my birthday wish
me happy birthday and you know I just
feel honors but I you know I wish likes
nothing but the best and I encourage
everybody to go out there and support
him and you know his recovery because I
know it's gonna be getting back to
normality it's gonna be you know it's
gonna be a challenge but he I know he
has the mindset for and he any and he
basically said you know he's you know
he's born for this this is what he's
mourning he's born for and he's gonna
hopefully be able to inspire people
motivate people into his process so much
respect to him man yeah much respect
mean it's flex which it's uh one of you
know when you look up to you grow up
looking to up to guys like that and it
just admiring them and just thinking how
incredible they are and then they become
your friends and you you know you're
able to you know you know communicate
with them and be friendly because we
sold brother number one buy and it's
just it's just a crazy crazy small world
when those things happen so you know
it's honor and like I said I wish you
know hope another was the best for
flexing through this process man I know
he's you know he's dealing with it but I
know that's that same tenacity yeah he
he was able to be a champion with you
he'll pull it out a lot of people are
rooting for a man a lot of so what we're
gonna do is we'll put the Instagram
account below just go follow flex and
give him some lobby sawed the brain and
curry give a shout out to be good for
him to hear from anybody saying brand
and give them just kind of love top five
favorite bodybuilders who's your top
five I asked everybody I'm curious I
know what you're gonna say I mean it's
good I mean flex would has to be one of
them of course Ronnie Lee Haney in any
specific like who's your at the top now
well just put them all down and now so
okay got it so flex Ronnie Haney
Phil Heath Philly Sergio Livia search
you Olivia yeah very interesting
okay is that is that is that that's five
so you're not putting Arnold here okay
well of course Arnold but I'm thinking
about top five
yeah of course Arnold Lee Haney Lee
Haney will be on top for me okay and
then you got Ronnie Ronnie second Wow
definitely eight eight yeah I know
Ronnie we got a we got Arnold okay Phil
flexor Sergio Phil flex Sergio so flex
number one you put in fifth yeah very
interesting Phil flexors yo Joe Haney
Ronnie
Arnold Phil flex surgery and this has
nothing to do with has nothing to do
with just physique only because you know
I think I hate hate he's just epitome of
of what I think is you know a complete
man in general especially you know
example you know body strength strength
you know just the mentality yes a
businessman whatever maybe he just is
just something like it definitely every
day
Ronnie you know Ronnie the
hardest-working coolest coolest
laid-back dude man I mean I love Ronnie
man he's a great guy and you know just
to see his strength man is incredible I
mean I've been at the table with even
breakfast knowing he's in pain no one
he's uncomfortable but me never let you
know it you're never he's like I'm gonna
enjoy this just like everybody else like
I'm not going through anything
as something that man you just you just
can't make that you know I can't wait
for that and by the way you know the
Yates also said that about Haney like
Yates said the guy that I saw was Haney
cuz he was so disciplined and he was ran
his life his marriage everything it was
so he's almost like the playbook to
follow him to have a good career you
know painting have we reshot to Haney
Adorno maybe we've had to reach out to
it I don't think we have we got it we
got to definitely reach out to be handy
tattoos and y'all so we'll definitely do
that we'll definitely do that last thing
here I want to give you a name tell me
the first thing that comes to your mind
one word that comes through my eye
Arnold Schwarzenegger legacy Joe Weider
hmm Empire Phil Heath attitude Wow
during aids tenacious abdul-allah Tybee
[Laughter]
represents having fun always hardship on
incredible body blow very cool from Iran
he's from Iran and yeah very very very
polished very very very good bye buddy
you tell he's he studied the sport
definitely you think he's got a career
like meaning he's gonna keep climbing I
mean if he can keep coming back he's
definitely you definitely set a
precedent in this stage he's very
polished Mike you got to be on your
a-game when you're on stage with me
because hottie hottie understands the
advantages of the gay the game you
notice I played a stage game that was
guys wouldn't where's a hottie in that
wait I didn't study him but I did but
yeah he's a very very good body butter
Sergio Olivia Sergio Olivia was is the
myth man he's just as complex I see I
know a son and son talks about him for a
personal level I just know us so I know
too much so yeah it kind of ruins it for
me
cool Lee Amy Lee Haney example example
okay Rollie Rollie man big kid my
brother Dexter
og largest of all time one of the
greatest thoughts really definite Wow
cuz when a witness of all time he's one
of the most consistent buddy was ever
and I give it a last one Brandi you man
I say Brandi was like a breath of fresh
air when I met her she's been like they
said to you know rib he's definitely
somewhere support me all the time close
to me all the time I wouldn't be I do
this without her cuz she helps me
navigate through this through this world
through the business side of it through
communication you know she's just she's
definitely by my side and I need her and
I and I'd value what she does for me
because I allow her to be strong where
she is so I mean like you will believe
this but I'm I well you maybe you would
you if you heard my story you would know
you know I was at a point in my life as
a high school where I was I was kind of
trying to be that Playboy and I had the
audacity the audacity to you know say to
challenge to challenge God in a way to
say you know if you want me to do this
because I was something wrong about it
dancer who my wife is well he showed me
brandy and I met her soon after that in
high school and he took us seven years
from there to kinda get get married but
yeah it happened so be careful the only
other time my mom when I told my mom
about it she was like wait because the
only time I'm not a mama's boy but when
I came to told her that she was like
what she remembered it she remembered it
probably better than I did it at the
time she was she she's the one I told my
wife about and I didn't even tell her
after we got married she's like you know
everybody knew everybody knew around me
anyway that's cool though that's good
you know that's that's great to hear
that you know when I see the two of you
guys together you can see the you know
the chemistry between the two it's
really a unique when you see it final
thoughts here for you I know 2020 you've
made it very clear you're excited about
next year crushing it and competing in
going for two time and I know you're
about to open up a gym you got coming up
in 2020 want you to tell us about that
yeah a carbon-carbon culture is a new
project we're working on its body
Buddhist gym true athletes gym strength
gym you know you have the model of you
know you know we just come here to try
to get our Fitness on now we come here
to get results we come here to work hard
so you have you know you'll have
trainers on site there to work with you
were the strength with your bodybuilding
physique whether you're just an average
person will have a glute section for the
ladies so you just want to come in and
just trash the glutes and not have
everybody gawking over them we've have
opposing room or progress room with some
people call it so you know the trans can
want to success and be Arsenal outfitted
all the latest Arsenal equipment and we
just want people to come in and be able
to get it done our our sabar is gonna be
crazy
you'd be to do your own formulations at
the bar but we'll talk about that later
it's cool yes that's really except you
want to experiment with different things
you will have clinical doses of
different substance and you can be able
to make some mix mix and match the way
you want and the doses that you want so
is words it words the first one gonna
the first one is gonna be in Franklin
Tennessee okay well we look to open up
one in Nashville as well Franklin
Tennessee man I used to date a girl from
Franklin Tennessee in the army when I
was in the other ways to go party in
Nashville I asked you earlier if you
partied in the Nashville Scene you said
not really so and I talked about mix
factories you said you remember when I
had a short stint of partying before I
got old yes in Nashville he's gone a
misfit mix Factory was one of those
places I wanna know strange places in a
strange place to go to any other
stranger places like the connections or
no was it just a connections I don't
know if I would see connections when it
was connections I used to have that
NASCAR cafe down and they turn into a
club I think it been was two different
names there was another place up there
called it underground it was someplace
crazy
let me tell me not from Elaine I've gone
to nice clubs but Nashville was very
weird it's even crazier I think now I
know more of a party town now than it
was back then I think there's no they
want them they took me to a club
Silverado Silverado number Silverado
Silverado and I was lying dance I'm like
a Middle Eastern I'm doing and they had
the hard body contest you know you'd go
there Silverados but it was a different
audience than the other places but
anyways man hey first of all much
respect to you for coming out man and
sitting here and being willing to talk
about all these different issues that
really enjoyed this conversation felt
like a five-minute conversation we went
through a lot of things and I'm looking
forward to you having an incredible
you're going into 2020 and a lot of the
projections you made with folks wanted
to come compete to make the brand big
again and I hope mr. Olympia brand
listen to some of these ideas and maybe
they'll process some of it and come back
and said we got to do something with
this so hopefully you know we you know
we can always you know change things to
communication and so hopefully this
creates more communication
and then working out in a favor for
everybody in for still man my man thanks
for coming out brother thank you
appreciate you so a couple things if
you're enjoying these mr. Olympia
nervous we're doing whether it's Phil
Heath and you know Dorian Yates or now
Brandon curry let us know who else you
want to see by commenting below or send
me a tweet directly and my handle is
Patrick where David and you can tag
anybody else you want to see because
I'll get that directly and on top of
that I got two other interviews I want
you to watch one is what prompted this
interviews with Dorian years which is a
jam-packed interview with a lot of
topics we covered or my first sit-down
Woodfill heath where we talked about the
future of mr. Olympia brand if you want
to see during the eighth's click here if
you want to see Phil Heath click here
and regardless if you haven't subscribed
to the channel please do so take
everybody bye-bye
[Music]